of all the Android launch devices the
nexus one will always hold a special
place in my heart that's not to take
anything away from my first android
device the HTC g1 that launched Android
to the world with its distinctive chin
and slide out keyboard or the HTC magic
first pre-release android phone i got to
dog food when I joined Google and the
first of the wave of devices we gave
every attendee starting at Google i/o in
2009 2010 was the year Android went from
that's interesting to global phenomenon
growing from a hundred thousand
activation today in May to over 300,000
by December that was seriously helped by
the release of the motorola droid i can
still remember the opposite here in
building 44 echoing with the constant
refrain of droid as each device rebooted
the droid was the first of the thinner
higher res more powerful Android devices
that have since become standard and it
was also the device whose released on
verizon here in the US really kicked off
the flood of android activations but i
was a Londoner then and the droid was a
cdma only phone so it was never really a
device i truly used then there was the
nexus one codenamed passion the first
device i felt was pure android was also
the phone we brought with us on our 2010
android developer labs world tour me and
my colleagues traveled across the world
seven cities in 10 days introducing over
20,000 developers to Android by way of
presentations and a free nexus one as a
result I made a lot of friends across
Europe and learned exactly how many
boxes of phones i can carry across
snowdrifts in stockholm and icy roads in
berlin since then the nexus s 4 and 5
have each improved on what it takes to
make a great android phone and OEMs
across the world have created thousands
of different Android devices starting
with the motorola xoom which led
androids official expansion into tablets
and leading the way for the Nexus 7 and
10 but that was just the start those
changes paved the way for the android
mobile OS to grow until it could be the
brains behind anything from phones and
tablets to TVs cars and wearables like
android where it's impossible to know
what comes next who knows maybe the next
android of
Isis will be androids themselves